هذا هو الطريق الرئيسي المؤدي إلى
المحطة الرئيسية لأكبر
مطار في إسرائيل، مطار بن غوريون، لكن اليوم
قرر المتظاهرون الذين خرجوا منذ أسابيع أن يجلبوا
يوم التعطيل هنا، وهدفهم هو
محاولة إغلاق المطار تقريبًا.
ليس فقط لتعطيل
الركاب لتوعيتهم بسبب
احتجاجهم ولكن أيضًا لأن
اليوم هو اليوم الذي من
المفترض أن يهبط فيه وزير الدفاع الأمريكي لويد أوستن
هنا للقاء المسؤولين
وأيضًا رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو.  أقلع من
هنا بعد الاجتماع مع أوستن للسفر
في رحلة رسمية إلى إيطاليا، ولذا
يحاول المتظاهرون هنا بشكل أساسي
منع حدوث ذلك،
وبدلاً من ذلك يصل بنيامين إلى المطار بطائرة
هليكوبتر، هؤلاء المحتجون على الرغم من أننا
تحدثنا من بينهم إلى
طيارين عسكريين سابقين  طيارو الطائرات المقاتلة السابقون
الذين يقولون إنهم يشعرون كما لو أنهم
لن يقاتلوا بعد الآن من أجل بلد
ما إذا كانوا لا يعتقدون أنه لم يعد
ديمقراطيًا. الآن لا تزال حركة المرور
تتحرك وإن كانت ببطء، لقد تحدثنا أيضًا
إلى بعض الركاب الذين  اضطروا إلى الخروج
من سياراتهم لأخذ حقائبهم
باليد والسير على طول الطريق حتى
المحطة من أجل القيام برحلاتهم
ولكن بعضهم يتقبلون
المتظاهرين هنا قائلين إنهم
يفهمون ما يقاتلون من
أجله.  بالطبع، يؤيدون كل
هذا المتعلق بالإصلاحات القضائية
التي تحاول حكومة نتنياهو
القيام بها، فهم يريدون بشكل أساسي
تمكين
البرلمان الإسرائيلي ذلك الكنيست من إلغاء
قرارات المحكمة العليا بأغلبية بسيطة،
لكن هذه الاحتجاجات تقول فقط
إنها ستستمر  بالخروج إلى
الشوارع سيستمرون في هذه
الأيام من التعطيل حتى يمنعوا هذه
الإصلاحات من المرور عبر بيكي